at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start shake
this episode is brought to you by
gymnastic bodies calm this is the
training system that I am most obsessed
with at the moment and I don't get paid
any Commission's or anything like that
you may have heard coach summer on the
podcast who designed the program former
national team coach for men's gymnastics
I am not easily impressed and I've just
been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming and
the elegance of his programming I've
been using gymnastic bodies for just a
few months now and I feel more flexible
stronger and younger than I have in
years and it sounds cheesy to hear
myself say that but it's true that's the
hardest part to believe and you can
check it out gymnastic bodies calm
forward-slash Tim if you go to that
landing page gymnastic bodies calm
forward-slash Tim you can take a look at
the fundamentals course which I'll help
you diagnose your weakest points areas
to improve etc and I highly encourage
you take a look at this bodyweight
training system it is incredible
gymnastic bodies calm forward-slash Tim
this podcast is brought to you by trunk
club I hate shopping with a passion and
you guys know this and I'm honestly not
any good at it anyway which means I end
up looking like I'm colorblind or
homeless this is where trunk club comes
in which provides you with your own
personal stylist and makes it easier
than ever to shop for clothes that look
great on your body even if you suck at
picking clothing just go to trunk club
comm forward slash Tim and answer a few
questions and then you'll be sent a
trunk full of awesome clothes so they
base this on your sizes preferences all
that jazz the trunk is then delivered
free of charge both ways so you only pay
for clothes that you keep so you have
prepaid stickers and whatnot if you keep
none it costs you nothing it's super
easy trunk club is not a subscription
service which I wanted to avoid there
are no
monthly fees also wanted to avoid that
your stylist is free shipping is always
free and you have ten days to try on the
clothes risk-free and trunk club is
backed by Nordstrom which means they
have the highest standards and quality
and customer service if you care about
saving time or looking good check it out
a trunk club.com forward slash Tim again
that's trunk club.com
forward slash Tim hello ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
or it is usually my job to deconstruct
world-class performers to tease apart
the habits routines favorite books etc
dozens of things that you can act on
from people ranging from chess prodigies
to four-star generals special ops
commanders to billionaires everybody in
between professional athletes you name
it in this particular episode we have an
in-between Assad with Seth Godin his
last episode which covers a lot of his
bio and everything else we really dug
into the weeds super fun is long that
one was about two two and a half hours
long this one is short it's about thirty
minutes long and you can think of it as
philosophical steroids that listen to
this it takes a couple minutes to get
warmed up so be patient but there are
some incredible gems and I listened to a
few times including how to keep track of
the right things and creating a
narrative that serves you as opposed to
handicaps you it's very very simple but
it's a foundational skill and mindset
that I try to practice myself and this
was a fantastic reminder they're just
some really pithy actionable things that
you can implement and I would suggest
that you reflect on in journaling and so
on Seth is the author of 17 Veselin
books he is at this is Seth's blog on
Twitter they've been translated into
more than 35 languages he writes about
the way ideas spread marketing strategic
quitting leadership and most of all
challenging the status quo in all areas
his books include and I'm sure many of
you have read more than one linchpin
tribes the dip Purple Cow what to do
when it's your turn and it's always your
turn he's founded companies
his blog which you can find by typing
Seth into Google is one of the most
popular in the world in 2013 he was
inducted into the direct marketing Hall
of Fame and he is constantly shaking
things up and pushing the envelope
testing the impossible very very
brilliant guy and with all of that said
please enjoy this round two with Seth
Godin thanks Tim for having me what a
pleasure to be back I will start by
pointing out how erudite intelligent
good-looking generous and thoughtful
most of the people who listened to this
podcast are I was optimistic that as we
dive through these questions and as Tim
continues the long arc of what he's
trying to talk about people will see
over and over again that in in an
economy based on connection real
connection comes from people who seek to
contribute to the community first and
that that asset the trust that comes
from that is priceless so looking
through these questions skipping the one
about why I look like a lizard and a few
other questions that have to do with
what it was like to be in a movie with
James Franco who I've never met so I've
never been in a movie with James Franco
I find that there are a few groupings
one grouping was talking about education
and parenting another grouping was the
mechanics of marketing and I would say
the biggest grouping was an
understanding of the fear that each of
us has to deal with in order to do this
original work
I tried alphabetizing the questions in
grouping admit I failed at that so maybe
what I'll do is go through them and as
they prompt other thoughts I'll weave
those together so let's start with James
Roloff who kicked us off for the
question what's the one thing that most
marketers do wrong
and this is easy we're selfish we are
narcissists infantile narcissists who
believe that our need for more and our
desire for attention
Trump's everything else we justify and
rationalize our work and interrupt
people spam people yell at people
deceive people and playing a short-term
game again and again and again
successful marketers are successful
because they don't do that and it turns
out that that's scarce
the folks who are willing to build a
story that's true to earn permission to
create a product or service that spreads
merely because it's remarkable that
mindset almost never shows up
next question from Pavan kanwa how do
you build a tribe from scratch so the
idea of tribes I think is fundamental to
humanity it's been around for thousands
of thousands of years but in the modern
world in which we live we can get
confused because it might seem that our
job is to build a tribe from scratch but
most of the time that's not what happens
Nike did not invent the running tribe
there were already runners before Nike
showed up harley-davidson did not invent
the outsider tribe a group that called
themselves the 1% long before the other
1% showed up that what we do when we
lead a tribe often is we find people who
are already connected and we merely show
up to lead them and for most businesses
most opportunities we don't even lead
them we merely service a tribe that
already exists so that when you find a
group of people who shared instinct and
interest a connection a leader of goal
and you give that group of people
something with which they can take
action the way I appreciate that long
sentence is people like us do things
like this
you are able to say people like us do
things like this then you have found a
tribe that can revolve around what you
do switching over to the fear side Jenny
Westerkamp asked what limiting self
beliefs did I change in order to become
successful and how did I change them
this was actually work that I did on
myself in college and have tried to
continue doing myself for a long time
since then the self limiting beliefs in
fact all of us because all of us like
being competent we like being respected
we like being successful and when
something shows up that threatens to
undo all of those things well then it's
really easy to avoid it and what goes
hand-in-hand with that is the sour
mindset the mindset of we are not
getting what we deserve the mindset of
the world is not fair the mindset of why
should I even bother it's probably not
going to work and one thing those of us
who are lucky enough to live in a world
where we have enough we have a roof and
we have food is we find ourselves caught
in this cycle of keeping track of the
wrong things keeping track of how many
times we've been rejected keeping track
of how many times it didn't work keeping
track of all the times someone has
broken our heart or double-crossed us or
let us down of course we can keep track
of those things but why why keep track
of them are they making us better
wouldn't it make more sense to keep
track of the other stuff to keep track
of all the times it worked all the times
we took a risk all the times we were
able to brighten someone else's day that
when we start doing that we can redefine
ourselves as people who are able to make
an impact on the world
and it took me a bunch of cycles to
figure out that the narrative was up to
me and if a narrative isn't working well
then really
why are you using it the narrative isn't
done to you the narrative is something
you choose and once we can dig deep and
find a different narrative then we ought
to be able to change the game so moving
just a tiny bit sideways from this chill
ellington best name of anyone who asked
the questions so far
asks my opinion on quality versus
quantity in the age of the constant
hustle mindset in online marketing can
you win without being everywhere of
course you can the real question is can
you win while being everywhere none of
us are everywhere there are most of the
people on earth have never heard of you
or bee and most of the people online
have never connected with either of us
it's a trap
a giant trap a trap designed to suck our
attention and our content away from us
and give us very little in return
maybe a little heart-shaped thing or
button that points up or a trend that
makes us feel like we did a good job
this is all a trap this isn't what's
causing people to succeed it's not
causing people to be able to make the
impact that they seek my suggestion is
whenever possible ask yourself what's
the smallest possible footprint I can
get away with what is the smallest
possible project that is worth my time
what is the smallest group of people who
I could make a difference for or two
because smallest is achievable smallest
feels risky because if you pick smallest
and you fail now you've really screwed
up we want to pick B because infinity is
our friend infinity is safe infinity
gives us a place to hide so I want to
encourage people instead toilet for the
small to be on one medium in a place
where people can find you to have one
sort of interaction with one tribe with
one group where you don't have a lot of
lifeboats this is what you do this is
what people need to look to you for so
before I dive into a bunch of good
questions about education
I wanted to talk about the long cut one
of the cultures it's present on the
Internet is this idea of the short cut
the life hack the way to get into the
innards of a system more quickly and
easily I'm an outspoken proponent of the
long cut because it seems to me that the
long cut is the most direct route to get
to where you seek to go that the brands
that we are aligned with the
institutions that we care about the
people we admire they all took the long
cut the long cut is the Beatles planning
in Hamburg for months and months or Bob
Marley slowly but surely working his way
from where he was to where he ended up
there's a long cut is a different game
it's not given get it's not even giving
giving giving yet it's just what does
this community need and more important
how do I do a kind of work that matters
that's mine and mine alone that's
identified with me that's difficult so
whenever possible I'm looking for the
long cut because it turns out that that
is the single best way to make the
change that we seek to have happen which
leads to education Carlota Angelou asked
us about public school and I've got
Bucky a question here from Jason hobby
who wants to know how I would approach
mastermind groups there are other people
who have asked about the alt NBA
including two of the alt NBA grads we're
following you I'm looking for their
names of mystical Justin Taylor wants to
know how the alt NBA would look for
grades K to 12
John Robinson and Bill O'Neill both
asked questions about it as well so here
we go
then stop stealing dreams I basically
pointed out that public school is an
artifact of the Industrial Age that it
was invented by industrialists who need
compliant factory workers this model is
fading it's leaving people in hundreds
of
thousands of dollars in debt without the
jobs that they seek the idea that you
could go to someone and say tell me what
to do and then they will pay you a lot
of money is fading faster than ever and
it's being replaced by people who know
how to do two things which is what I
think school ought to be teaching one
how to solve interesting problems
meaning how to do a thing you can't look
up on the Internet meaning how to do
something where no one can tell you how
to do it and to lead have the guts to
say follow me these things are in scarce
supply and the main reason they're in
scarce supply is because people aren't
taught to do them and our culture isn't
organized around them so what do we do
about school well the first thing we do
when it comes to thinking about
parenting is not to tolerate but to
embrace the idea of free range kids kids
who are learning what works by figuring
out what doesn't that the lessons that
we remember are the lessons we learned
the hard way I can't remember the last
time I said to myself oh when I was in
fifth grade or seventh grade or tenth
grade we read about this in the textbook
but I remember really well something I
screwed up at second grade and then I
learned how to fix on my own so when the
kid comes home with a solid b-plus
average and then one grade that to
c-minus the industrialist mindset is
cause trouble around the c-minus figure
out how to make someone well-rounded
help them understand how important it is
to meet spec the alternative is to
encourage our kids to find things that
don't work to experiment with things
that they're not good at to explore yet
another thing that didn't turn out right
if they approach it in the right spirit
if they approach
with the right intent and that process
of learning through exploration is too
often missing now one of the ideas that
I'm really enamored with is the idea of
enrollment enrollment is not what
happens when you sign up with the nearby
school and then they threaten to throw
the parents in jail if the kid doesn't
show up in class enrollment is what we
call it when someone is eagerly present
when a consultant has enrollment from a
client the client is saying to her yes
we want to move forward show us how as
opposed to the consultant I'm going to
cajole and push and basically encourage
the client to go forward enrollment is
different moment is something we want to
do so the key element of the autumn day
begins with enrollment in that you're
not there to get a piece of paper
because there isn't one you're not there
because it's accredited because it's not
you're there because you want to level
up then online courses like Coursera
which Michael Sweeney passed about and
other MOOCs and self-directed learning
all of them work best when they are
things we choose to do there's an
important distinction because most of
the education that most of us have had
is not education we enrolled for or if
we did enroll we enrolled once at the
beginning and then we were waiting for
the two-year MBA to be over or we were
waiting for the driver ed class to be
over we weren't actually seeking to
engage in the work itself so all we have
to figure out how to do whether it's for
third graders or for a MOOC is continue
to amplify this cycle of enrollment
continue to create an environment where
people would miss it if there was a snow
day they would miss it
if someone said we don't have to do that
page there's a famous bar review of
course that used to happen in New York
called peeper and what people would do
you paid thousands of dollars to take
this course is he would stand in front
of the class and read his notes and then
every once in a while he'd want to stop
and tell him anecdote so he would say
not for your notes and everyone would
drop their pencil and start talking to
each other
ignoring him until he would then say
notes no one took the bar exam course
because they wanted to learn something
they all took the bar exam course so he
get the bar exam over with and I think
what we're seeing in our culture now as
it's being rearranged is we get to do
what we want to do if we care enough but
caring enough means we've got to figure
out how to move forward we have to
figure out where the fear is and engage
with it so every question here from
weight Johnston do I ever have fear if
so how does he deal with it and if not
when did it stop well I don't think it's
ever going to stop and I most of people
I know aren't sociopaths and Psychopaths
they have fear as well
fear is hardwired into us fear kept our
ancestors alive fear isn't stupid
but lately fear is incorrectly processed
that being afraid of public speaking is
a bug in our operating system because
public speaking isn't actually dangerous
it just feels dangerous can you make the
fear go away well some people say they
can I'm not sure that it's true I think
that what we can do is dance with the
fear so one of the things we do in the
old NBA is we put people through 13
different projects in public some group
some solo and one of the reasons for
that is to create a cycle of shipping
why because once you get into the cycle
of shipping you begin to a so
the fear with producing work of value
and that idea that you can use fear as a
compass that you can say why is this
making me nervous maybe that nervousness
is pointing me where I need to go not
the other way around okay
jumping around a little bit David
mooring wants to know if I didn't have
my blog my email is my books my network
how would I go about building a tribe
and making a ruckus today starting with
zero given the amount of noise and the
amount of content produced today do I
think I could go back to my current
level of prominence and impact you know
my current level of prominence and
impact is largely based on Locke I
showed up a lot but so did a lot of
other people I wrote a lot but so did a
lot of other people I had some good
ideas but so there's a lot of other
people and every day I remind myself
that someone had to get lucky in certain
respects and it was me there are other
things I tried other things I built that
didn't work other people got lucky in
those areas not me
I'm not vain enough to believe that it's
all my doing
you know I won the parent lottery I grew
up in the right decade in the right
country at the right time and some lucky
breaks along the way made a big
difference but that wasn't your question
your question was how would I make an
impact today here's where we get back to
that idea of the smallest possible
market too often and I really don't like
the blog posts about companies that
raised another ten million dollars the
companies that were valued at another 50
million dollars who don't even have a
product yet this is not news this is not
success this is another step along the
road but it's not something that we need
to aspire to what those organizations
are generally doing they're exceptions
but what they are generally doing is
postponing the day they need to say to a
customer please pay me
that we do lots of things to hide from
that day we say we're planning we're
prepping we're raising money we're
trying for a bigger market what's wrong
with a small market can you create
something of value for three people can
you create something a value for nine
people
is there a tribe of 12 skateboarders
down the road that you could engage with
that you're gonna have an influence with
then you could make a profit with
because if you can't do it with 12 or
you can't do it with 20 or you can't do
it with 50 what makes you think you're
gonna be able to do it with five
thousand or fifty thousand it doesn't
get easier it gets the same that
postponing it waiting for the perfect
tribe waiting for the perfect idea the
perfect booktitle the perfect distict
that or worse looking for shortcuts and
hacks and ways to conceal ourselves from
what we're capable of doing I think
these are all mistakes I think the wind
the giant opportunity is to change one
person teach one person influence one
person find a market where someone needs
what you have so I started really
professionally as a soloist in 86
selling books to book publishers now in
1986 book publishers needed more books
than they had that almanacs and detailed
long pop books are hard to write there
weren't enough people who could write
them I was one of those people I built
the team that could package and create
these books and I am rejected again and
again and again and again until I
understood how to talk to people in that
industry in a way that they could hear
me in a way that they could understand
and respect and then I was able to sell
them and the magic of this is it pays
for itself you don't do the bulk until
someone pays for it and once they pay
for it you have enough money to do the
book so I didn't need funding
I didn't need somebody to support the
prospect of what I was doing because the
client was paying for it and that's not
always true there are certainly
important businesses that have been
built with a more slow approach where
people don't pay for a long time to come
where Google was busy you know being
Google for a lot of people before they
made a penny those businesses have a
place but they don't have to be your
business your business can be about
engaging with people who trust you
delivering value to them and making
enough money to do it again and we can
hide from this but we shouldn't pretend
that that's not the best plan going
public isn't the purpose selling your
company isn't the purpose the purpose is
creating value for someone who will pay
you for it so you can do it again so
then there's some questions about
personal brand john wants to know how i
define my own personal brand Neal's
vipin wants to know when the right time
you start working on your personal brand
is then there are a couple questions
here from people like Eric and Ian and
Jeff about how I pick what my next
project should be in what size I think
these are related so let me try what's
your brand is your brand your logo well
that's stupid because we're humans we
don't have logos so what is your brand I
think your brand is the promise that you
make implicitly or explicitly what do I
expect from you when I hire you when you
show up in my headphones when we engage
what's the promise brands they keep
their promises are consistent brands
they keep their promises earn trust and
through permission queerness you have a
brand whether you want one or not from
the minute you engage with your boss or
your co-workers or a prospect or
customer
or even the person at the Avis
rent-a-car counter you have a brand
you're branded as the impatient customer
who's not listening or your branded as
the calm professional who gets the job
done or you were branded as the
short-term hustler who's always looking
for an angle but yes you have a brand so
when did you start working on it
yesterday or a year ago or five years
ago if it's too late for that the next
best time is right now your brand is a
story and it's a story that helps people
tell themselves a story about you so
your appearance your handshake your
pricing how long it takes you to deliver
the goods where you're located your
accent how tall you are even the way you
spell your name are all parts of the
story that other people tell themselves
about you and most of those stories are
unfair most those stories are based on
prejudice and a lack of information and
fear and fear and fear the stories
people tell themselves about you are
never true they can't be no one knows
you as well as you do I've given a
thousand speeches no one has heard all
of them except for me right I've written
18 bestsellers most of you haven't read
all of them written 6,000 blog posts
again and again and again you go down
the list so many things we don't know
about you so many things we don't know
about what you're capable of what you
dream of what you want to produce so yes
you have a brand and no it's not the
same for everyone but it's up to you to
consistently and persistently show up in
a way that amplifies that brand that if
you are the kind of person that can
justify doing the next thing you do
because it's an emergency well that's
part of your brand on the other hand
there are things that others would do
that you wouldn't in this moment that
also is part of your brand so when I was
a book packager I had a brand
at the beginning which was that I was a
Stanford MBA who was going to great
pains to show how prepared he was and
professionally wasn't yes
smarter about the market and the editors
I was selling to and they responded to
my brand by buying nothing from me
because it didn't match the story they
needed to tell themselves about what
they were doing
so I deliberately and intentionally
changed my brand
stop putting spreadsheets in my
proposals stopped wearing a suit to my
meetings worked hard to listen to what
it was that they were trying to tell me
and what it was that they needed from me
so that I could deliver to them on the
promise they wanted me to make that
mindset requires you to commit to the
marketplace you want to be in because of
one minute you're selling steamed
shuffles and the next minute you're
selling life insurance and the minute
after that you're helping people beat a
traffic ticket no one can figure out who
you are no one can figure out what to
expect from you next so as my late
friend Zeke used to say there's a
difference between being a meaningful
specific and a wandering generality a
wandering generality is looking for the
next thing all the time and as a result
they can't possibly build a brand so
then Tom Mann says well how do I decide
what is essential indispensable for what
is useless to pay my attention not it
comes back to the brand to the promise
to what you stand for and as Michael
Schrag is pointed out to the change that
you were seeking in the world if you
were trying to make a specific change it
becomes much easier to decide what is
essential you're trying to make a
specific change to a specific person or
group of people it becomes much easier
to not be abstract but specific that as
Jack just is wondering about yes there
is practical advice once you decide
what change you are seeking to make that
it's really not that difficult for Nike
to decide to do something or not do
something because they stand for
something because they've made a promise
should Nike get into the corn chip
business well they could probably make
money in corn chips at least for a while
because they have a lot to invest and
they know how to run ads and they have
distribution however corn chips don't
match the story that Nike is telling to
the people they're trying to tell it to
I'll give you a little brandy aside here
the story is told years ago that Nike
was sold in Sears stores and that Nike
and Sears had an agreement that Sears
would never run an ad in the sunday
circulars the ephah size that ran in the
sunday paper for Nike shoes well some
low-level person at Sears meaning well
ran an ad once and Nike responded by
pulling all of their products from every
Sears store in America well that freaked
out the leaders at Sears and they
frantically called and called Phil
Knight to see if they could fix things
and Phil Knight refused to speak to them
so taking matters into their own hands
they flew to the west coast to Oregon to
meet with him and Phil had them sit in
the lobby not outside his office but in
the main lobby of the Nike building from
9 o'clock in the morning 5 o'clock at
night and then he sent them home now I
don't think I would ever humiliate
somebody like that but he did it for a
reason because every one of his
employees walked past these two people
from Sears sitting in the lobby being
punished in public because they had done
something that didn't match the promise
that Nike was trying to make part of
Nikes promise was the big retailers
which is we're not going to treat you
particularly well because we stand for
something other than treating the
retailer's really well but a big part of
the promise was we're serious about what
we do and how we do it
and our customers understand that and we
need to understand it as well so part of
what we seek when we build one of these
brands as a human is a narrative
boundaries a way of figuring out what we
stand for and what we don't stand for
not to everyone but to the people we are
seeking to change and one of the reasons
why I'm not a big fan of online comments
his online comments are open to everyone
not the people you seek to change online
comments are anonymous not the people
you seek to change so hearing from those
people will push you to be more average
more normal more a low-key more in the
middle but that's not where brands are
built brands are built around the edges
we have a couple questions here about
Purple Cow about standing up in a field
where everyone is trying to Mir go in
Putra and tone rosna your instead ask
similar questions how will marketing
change as more people leave full time to
get into the gig economy how are we
supposed to stand out in a crowded field
how can you keep the cow purple well
you're right neo philia the desire for
the new eats its own young it means that
Jackson Pollock is old fashioned it
means that Hamilton is yesterday's play
or it will be one day soon that if you
decide to live on that edge sign up for
what you're getting and what you're
getting is this industry where what's
new is the dominant question but it
turns out human beings don't merely need
that what human beings really need is to
be connected to be seen to be understood
to get what they need when they need it
and that means that you can find a group
of people it doesn't have to be very
many where you are the consistent
regular choice you're not going from neo
affiliates in this place you're going
for people who are happily engaged in
the center of the market doing
productive work and when you become the
key supplier to these people you're not
getting that gig because you do a
commodity a little cheaper than everyone
else you're getting that gig because
you're better better knowing them better
being flexible better at going the
extra-mile
better at keeping the promises that we
onion commoditize our work by making our
work more human and that is so hard
because when you make it human it means
you're responsible and responsibility is
different than authority
responsibilities taken authority is
given so we can each take more
responsibility by becoming better at our
craft trusted by a group of people who
need and want to hear from us okay and
to wrap this up we have questions from
Jeff's or and from a few other people
about how I choose projects what scale I
want the projects to be how I keep from
getting distracted in the middle of a
project my answer here and for the
people who want me to give you practical
step-by-step bullets I apologize but my
answer here is simple at some point you
need to decide who you are you need to
decide the scale of what you built you
need to decide what the brand is when
people hire you when they engage with
you I used to make 700 page reference
books with teams of four or five people
who would work for over a year to make
something that could really stand the
test of time that's a choice I was able
to go into a publisher and confidently
say I do that do I do Broadway shows no
do I do TV series no I do this and we
can't once we pick our scale and our
project jump to the next thing instantly
nor can we complain that picking one
scale keeps us from doing the other
thing we have to embrace it the fact is
it helps us that we have a cynic you
then we help that we have a niche that
we have a thing that we do
then when other people want to be in our
space just for kicks they can't because
they're not fuss at our scale with our
contribution to make and so when we look
at social media when we look at all the
opportunities when we look at all the
conferences we can go to we say to
ourself does this advance me in the
change I am trying to make to the
community does this help my customers
because it makes it easier for me to
keep my promises years ago my dad who
used to run the biggest Hospital Cooke
company in the country bought a laser
cutter not one of those little
Kickstarter laser cutters a laser cutter
that cost a million dollars by the laser
cover that cost a million dollars when
you run a multi-million dollar hospital
quick company is a really smart thing to
do because that asset and it's an asset
you own it you use it that asset enabled
him to transform the quality of what he
was making the time to market it helped
him make all of his promises better
that's what happens once you own the
decision so I'm gonna finish by thanking
you and Tim again
and hope that you've taken away from
this and thank you for lending me your
time these ideas about fear and the
compass and the promises and the brand
and about doing work that's yours and
yours alone and owning it and connecting
to people finding a tribe and
contributing to them I hope you'll go
make a ruckus Thanks
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy this
podcast is brought to you by Trump club
I hate shopping with a passion and you
guys know this and I'm honestly not any
good at it anyway which means I end up
looking like I'm colorblind or homeless
this is where trunk Club comes in which
provides you with your own personal
stylist and makes it easier than ever to
shop for clothes that look great on your
body even if you suck at picking
clothing just go to trunk club comm
forward slash Tim and answer a few
questions and then you'll be sent a
trunk full of awesome clothes they base
this on your sizes preferences all that
jazz the trunk is then delivered free of
charge both ways so you only pay for
clothes that you keep so you have
prepaid stickers and whatnot if you keep
none it costs you nothing it's super
easy trunk love is not a subscription
service which I wanted to avoid there
are no monthly fees also wanted to avoid
that your stylist is free shipping is
always free and you have ten days to try
on the clothes risk-free and trunk club
is backed by Nordstrom which means they
have the highest standards and quality
and customer service if you care about
saving time or looking good check it out
at rump club.com
forward slash Tim again that's Trump
club.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
gymnastic bodies calm this is the
training system that I am most obsessed
with at the moment and I don't get paid
any Commission's or anything like that
you may have heard coach summer on the
podcast who designed the program former
national team coach for men's gymnastics
I am not easily impressed and I've just
been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming and
the elegance of his programming I've
been using gymnastic bodies for just a
few months now and I feel more flexible
stronger and younger than I have in
years and it sounds cheesy to hear
myself say that but it's true that's the
hardest part to believe and you can
check it out gymnastic bodies calm
forward-slash Tim if you go to that
landing page gymnastic bodies calm
forward-slash Tim you can take a look at
the fundamentals course which I'll help
you diagnose your weakest points areas
to improve etc and I highly encourage
you take a look at this bodyweight
training system it is incredible
gymnastic bodies calm forward-slash Tim
you